alright so today's draft as we sign off
for our hiatus until we return on July
29 the how what do we call it sports to
follow until training camp begins big
kid go ahead call call tails win the
toss and make the first pick
alright I'll say tails and I also want
to throw this out there that we're not
gonna baseball's a given so we're just
gonna throw a baseball ok watch baseball
anyway you won't but I do i watch every
Cubs game saw baseball is a given I'm
doing more off-brand sports so that we
can have fun with it
Mike you go first I'll defer to you well
it's not July without watching human
beings turn themselves into gluttons and
have it be applauded by anyone and
everyone who's paying attention the
Nathan's hot dog eating contest at a
disgusting display of where we are as a
society but also an integral part of the
4th of July celebration you're talking
very offensively there to someone who
has competed in it you know that right
how did you how many jus eat I ate 12
I'm not joking right now I don't know if
you knew that but I did compete in the
Nathan's hot dog on Coney Island on July
4th PETA ran up and threw fake blood all
over me I wonder every now yes--that's
can maybe find that picture before the
end of this but that was I mean I could
be I hate I had 12 hot dogs III was out
there I was a competitor I put a jersey
on I can speak as a former competitor so
if you need an expert to talk about it
I'm I'm open and willing to be
interviewed now how did and I don't want
to take this too far but did you manage
to retain the 12 hot dogs yeah there's
just so much sodium and food that you
can't really even even if you tried it
would be hard to to throw them back up
so yeah they're kind of stuck there yeah
yeah all right that's good pick that's
good pick I'm gonna start with how about
a little bags or corn whole they've been
throwing this on TV a lot
so bags championship cornhole
championship whatever you want to call
it it is fun to watch it is the ultimate
athletes who are not athletes because
they look just like us guys at a
tailgate but they're competing
real money and they're fantastic at what
they do like if you watch one of these
bags tournaments
it is incredible watching how good these
guys are and what they're able to do
with their shots it humbles you and it's
it's intense it's everything you want in
a sport that is an offbeat sport in June
or July cornhole is one of those things
that looks both easy but also impossible
at the same time and you can convince
yourself into thinking I can do this and
then you don't even come close to
hitting the board right you're right
that they chunk them in one after
another after another or or at or
they're all collected around the hole I
mean there's there's no hitting and
sliding it's in and it's in and it's
amazing to sit and there's nobody
missing the board so know that that's a
that's a good choice and that that's
that's a fun sport and there were plenty
of cornhole on TV coming up yeah over
the next few weeks all right
mine I've got it I've got a pander to
the corporate overlords here because
because while we're gonna be off a de
Tour de France tour of frost tour de
force is gonna be on so you know you
gotta watch the bike race the bike race
through the mountains it's gonna be the
centerpiece of the NBCSN coverage while
we are on hiatus and I'm grateful for
the Tour de France otherwise we'd have
to find football stuff to talk about for
three weeks in July so thank you bike
race I will I will watch you instead of
work over the next four weeks one note
make sure stats when you put up the
thing it says bag slash cornhole because
I know I'll get yelled out online if I
don't do that
why do we call it the it's a regional
thing people in the Midwest called bags
so you know if you say cornhole and then
say bag so just throw bag / cornhole why
do we say Tour de France when it's
France why do we do that it's France
it's right but it's France so why don't
wise out the Tour de France how do we do
I sound too like like an idiot American
when I said Tour de France that's how I
just never thought that about you ever
okay I will also pander for you how
about the fastest sport on two feet
lacrosse my friend Paul Rabil and the
PLL you can find it on NBC sports it is
fantastic to watch if you're trying to
get into a new sport it is the fastest
growing game out there I don't know what
exactly that means they just claim that
so I'm gonna go with it
shout out Tucker Durkin he's my favorite
player that's the only guy I know and
it's because Paul Raven said his name
when we interviewed him a couple weeks
ago and that's all that I know about I
just brain dumped everything I know
about lacrosse for you Mike right there
you know there's another player whose
initials are TB and he tried to do a TB
nine lacrosse stick and the Tom Brady TB
12 lawyers came in and shut that down we
were talking to worry about that a
couple of weeks ago I can't remember the
guys name all I know is he was trying to
do tb9
Tanner bode Tanner bode I don't think
that's who it was
it's another TB I think it's
coincidental all right here's my third
pick and look I I hey you can still
watch football on TV just because it's
not live you can put on NFL Network and
you can watch the NFL Films the greedy
greatest top ten this top ten that the
quarterback challenge that you got me
hooked on a few weeks ago thank you very
much for that while I was enjoying a
nice summer day outside I got to go in
and watch TV because I got to watch all
the awesome quarterback skills
competitions from years gone by so if
you want to stay out of the Sun you want
to avoid anything you make cause any
skin problems down the road watch NFL
Network and you'll see all of the this
stuff from yesteryear the great the
great football games of years gone by
and at least we'll feel like you're
watching football until real football
comes back okay that's cheating that's
fine you have to cheat to win that's
fine you are you know the Julian Edelman
of the Mount Rushmore the draft right
here there you happy I'm gonna finish
with monster trucks I'm hooked on
monster trucks now I watched that last
night the hands were so funny I didn't
realize there was a there was a truck
with with they look like a Dalmatian
with big ears there was a truck that
look like a dumpster truck I am all in
on monster trucks now what's the Oh
grave digger if grave diggers still out
there I don't know if he is that's an
all-time mountain monster truck that I
remember but I am a newfound monster
truck fan so I'll put that as my third
pick
they need to put hands on gravedigger
and also feet right you got back fenders
do it you can you can fo that alright
one that I considered and I know well
you know what we'll talk about that
later because it's what you're gonna be
talking about all weekend long so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna spoil that one
there were some others on the board
though you know we've got Wimbledon is
coming up that's usually a pretty big
deal they play on grass if you haven't
heard what else is going on this month
all the open the open it's not the
British Open it's the open we got to get
that right that's pandering to the NBC
coverage we have that on NBC that's
coming up later this month it's now the
fourth major because remember they moved
the PGA Championship the one that nobody
really paid attention to they tucked
that between the Masters and the US Open
so now the open is the the last one not
I don't know that that really matters
it's not like anybody's in position when
a grand slam but that's now the final
that's not that's the extent of my golf
knowledge the open is the final grand
slam now yeah Brooks Kefka my guy he's
probably gonna win it no big deal
he's a friend of mine and he's gonna win
it so if you have any questions again
I'm open for interviews on that how
close I am with Brooks koepka but yes
girlfriend hammer Blake bortles but
that's because I've known Blake for
longer but where you know you can have
milk you don't understand that you can
have multiple friends you have no
friends but I a guy who is very social a
social butterfly some may say I have
many friends I thought you were my
friend that changes everything
this is awkward now I have a 1/4 we have
to film
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports